nadège quelle est la situation de votre
côté ce que l'objectif là c'est de
rejoindre les champs-elysées pour
l'instant on ne sait pas trop l'objectif
premier c'est bien de rejoindre la
baisse de la porte de champerret c'est
ce qui était prévu annoncés déclaré
auprès de la préfecture de police de
paris en tout cas pour l'instant on est
dans le flou puisque sur sept on tourne
un petit peu en rond on est déjà passé
sur cette avenue de villiers il ya une
heure on repasse à nouveau est ce qui a
changé c'est que la tension est bien
elle semble avoir redescendu puisque
vous le voyez peut-être le cortège
reprend progresse à nouveau les forces
de l'ordre ont repris le contrôle sur la
situation elle avait été à déstabiliser
à plusieurs reprises
plusieurs policiers se sont retrouvés
nate et malgré eux par les manifestants
ils les ont à des heures aussi en
t'éclater entre manifestants et forces
de l'ordre wade à forces de l'ordre qui
ont répondu aux jets de projectiles par
des coups de matraque de tête
de lancement de gaz lacrymogène bon en
tout cas au moment où je vous parle la
situation s'est calmée et le cortège
reprend petit à petit donc les
revendications on le disait tout à
l'heure à tôt elle est même que depuis
le début du mouvement le 17 novembre
2018 hausse du pouvoir d'achat à une
demande pour plus de justice fiscale
environnementales et sociales et puis
elle à la mise en place de ce fameux
bric ce référendum d'initiative
citoyenne 6 et gilet jaune sont réunis
pour ce 2 septembre c'est aussi pour
manifester leur mécontentement en
impasse à la gestion
je cite désastreuse du gouvernement de
l'actrice
les sanitaires et de ce scandale des
masques qui avait éclaté en début de
l'épidémie de coronavirus certains
avaient manifesté une poignée 1 ne sont
d'ailleurs pas masqué aujourd'hui donc
voilà justement à propos des
revendications et la reprise de ce
nouveau
écouter certains manifestants
je reviens peut-être y en a beaucoup qui
disait à cesser et il faut laisser
tomber il faut laisser tomber
mais non faut jamais laisser tomber faut
absolument continuer à montrer qu'on
n'est pas contents parce qu'il fait
n'est pas normal ce gouvernement n'est
pas l'écrit double du tout voilà c'est
pour ça que je viens je vais le
démontrer absolument depuis la crise de
gilet jaune il aurait dû avoir un un
référendum et il ya jamais eu ce
référendum populaire
donc c'est tout simplement dit ni
démocratie pour moi pur et dur nous on
est là les medics pour soigner policiers
et manifestants
et voilà les policiers de du moins de
deux gradés on nous ont pris notre
matériel ont dit soit on vous donnez
votre matériel sont vous embarque alors
je suis là aujourd'hui parce que depuis
huit jours je suis à la retraite et
quand j'ai vu ce que je vais embrasser
une misère un mille euros pour 44 années
de travail mais j'ai fait beaucoup
d'autres manifs en tant que salarié pas
pour défendre notre notre vivre et non
notre survivre voilà faut acheter son
air dans un restaurant une terrasse tu
achètes un coca doit respirer
tu marches dans la rue tu achètes rien
ça devra d'avoir tomasky d'étouffer on
aura des problèmes tous huit heures de
marche comme ça ils vont avoir
tu vas voir dans un mois ce qu'on va
faire une manif vous allez tomber malade
et moi c'est pourquoi vous tombiez
malade que je me bats au défi les jeunes
qui vous l'avez donc entendu espère
redonner un second souffle à ce
mouvement de contestation inédit donc en
france d aj les jeunes qui progressent
visiblement direction de la place de la
porte de champerret actuellement dans le
calme et la bonne humeur et à vous on va
vous retrouver bien évidemment d'en
prendre deux prochaines éditions pour
faire un nouveau point sur cette
mobilisation des gilets jaunes et puis